it's a pleasure to be here I think it's
bit listen overdo visit to Stanford
probably I haven't been here for a long
time even the supposition might link me
for a long time but I'll talk about
memory system design and hopefully I'll
give you some hope that we still have
hope in this domain but before I start
very quickly what do I work on well
clearly I work on memory memory memory
storage and interconnects but I'm really
interested in computer architecture
hardware software interface and also by
informatics these are some of the things
that I my group looks at parallel
architectures heterogeneous
architectures GPUs we have big projects
relate to that I'm really interesting
crossing the boundaries and hopefully
you'll see teams of that in this talk
system architecture boundary as well as
the architecture circuits boundary and
going forward especially if you want to
design more scalable memory systems I
think need to cross those boundaries
even more than we have done in the past
so you'll see themes of energy
efficiency fault tolerance and hardware
security in this talk but basically
we're like doing broad research spanning
application systems on logic with
architecture at the center but that's
kind of that little picture I have
related to the research and one of my
interest is genome sequence analysis and
assembly and this is a problem where
it's it's really that wood that
motivates memory a lot I look at
algorithms in this area but it's it's
it's a it's an area it's a big data area
where we produce more data than we can
process today actually with the
next-generation sequencing technologies
which actually current generation but
I'll talk about memory in this talk and
what are we talking about basically main
memory sits in between processor and
caches and the storage and it's a
critical component in all computing
systems we design basically we need to
have some kind of working storage as
Andy mentioned earlier and this system
must scale in many many dimensions size
technology efficiency costs and the
algorithms we use to manage it if you
want to maintain the performance growth
and the technology scaling benefits and
this is another view of the memory
system this is my cartoonish picture of
it but there are two key points that I
would like to make over here one is if
you look at
the computation components in this
cartoonish picture they're they're
limited to the red parts basically
everything else is part of the memory
system if we were designing these notes
systems and there most of it is really
dedicated to moving and storing data and
if you even if you look at the red parts
internally a lot of it is dedicated to
moving and storing data we have the
registers and interconnected l1 caches
that I didn't paint and the second thing
is if you look at this most of the
memory system is shared across these
computational agents shared caches other
shared cache is shared memory
controllers shared memory shared
interconnects and that leads to quality
of service problems I'll briefly talk
about that today let me tell you a
little bit about the state of the main
memory system as I see it today there
are some recent technology architecture
and application trends that lead to some
new requirements is demand that also
exacerbate some old requirement and
we've always demanded a lot from the
system and we're demanding even more
opposite that DM and memory controllers
as we know them and as we design them
today are unlikely or they are not able
to satisfy all of these requirements and
I'll hopefully give you some evidence
from the field based on some of the
studies we've done and at the same time
there are some emerging memory
technologies that happen to be
non-volatile that enable some new
opportunities like the merging of memory
and storage so hopefully we'll get to
the end of the talk well I'll talk about
that given these I believe we need to
rethink the entire main memory system
and the system we design around it or
the systems we design around it
to fix the issues we're having with DRAM
and enable some of these emerging memory
technologies while satisfying all the
requirements that we demand from it so
the set outline of my talk this actually
this could be a really long talk this
could be days and days but I'm going to
compress it to one hour eight minutes
remaining feel free to ask questions I
may need to limit it given that we have
a time limitation but I'd be happy to
have a discussion afterwards or some
other time as well feel free to email me
but I'll talk about the major trends
affecting main memory and then I'll pose
everything as a memory scaling problem
and talk about two major solution
directions looking at new memory
architectures and enabling emerging
memory technologies and circle back and
talk about how we can do better draw
some principles hopefully hopefully none
of this will be surprising principles
because a lot of them will be applied
from some other domains and then I'll
summarize this isn't one slide the major
trends that are affecting main memory as
I see them
first we're demanding more memory
bandwidth capacity and quality of
service and this is really driven by
three major things we're putting
increasingly more computational agents
on the chip they're sharing the
bandwidth they're sharing the capacity
they're sharing the resources as a
result you have a predictability problem
applications are becoming increasingly
data intensive you have and this is not
going to change probably we're at the
points in in civilization today we're
generating the most data and we're going
to generate even more in my opinion and
we want to consolidate more and more
regardless of what every system you
design cell phone data center dot dot we
would like to put more applications
running on the node such that we can get
area cost and energy efficiency benefits
and this is driving the capacity
bandwidth and quality of service
requirements up this is just one example
the capacity gap the sector from a paper
that was published by HP Labs on
University of Michigan iske 2009
basically they plotted the core count
which is doubling approximately every
two years they applied the DMM capacity
three years and they've shown that
memory capacity per cores expect to drop
by 30% every two years now if the
program is relying on a thread getting
more memory such that you can write more
feature full software then that's not
going to happen
assuming you're utilizing your resource
as well and the trends are actually much
worse for memory bandwidth per core
memory bandwidth grows by approximately
10 percent every year with some bumps
maybe but basically we're designing
these systems where computation is
increasing growing much faster than we
can provide capacity and bandwidth
basically mister is starving the course
the second major system trend in memory
is energy and power is the key system
design concern and this has been like
that for a while
except it's getting much worse today
there's a really nice paper by Charles
lafurgey and others at IBM Research
where they published real data from big
iron systems of IBM in 2003 and they've
shown that approximately 40 to 50
percent of the entire system energy in
this big iron system to spent on the off
chip memory hierarchy including the off
chip interconnect off chip caches off
chip DRAM and off chip storage and
that's a big fraction and other people
have repeated the studies on mobile
systems and one issue we're having with
DRM is it consumes power even when it's
not used
we basically need to periodically
refresh it
that's actually a big scaling problem of
the UN today which brings me to my third
point DM technology scaling is ending
and offending is a strong word you can
choose the other word which is becoming
really difficult to deal with but ITRs
international technology roadmap of
semiconductors has been projecting for a
while that year and will not easily
scale below X nanometers anybody has a
value assigned to X tree wow that's
that's very optimistic maybe yeah we'll
see it may become 3 but definitely
driving that X down will be increasingly
more difficult for us and I'll hopefully
give you some evidence from the field
that we're actually seeing the scaling
issues feeling the scaling issues but
scaling what do I mean by scaling
basically reduce the size of the circuit
and that reduces that provides you many
benefits high capacity higher density
lower costs and hopefully reasonable
energy scaling and if this ends we're
not going to be able to satisfy these
requirements really well at least with
the technology the way we have known it
so let me pose everything as the memory
scaling problem and talk about some
motivate you a little bit more and then
talk about some solution directions so
what is the scaling problem we see with
DRM based the DRM like any other memory
has a storage device and an access
device and the storage device in DRM is
a capacitor access devices the access
transistor the bitline and the sense
amplifier over here and for this to work
well the capacitor must be large enough
to real for reliable sensing and this
access transistor must be large enough
for low leakage and high retention time
such that you don't you keep the charge
over here and this was actually the
value that was assigned to X by ITRs in
2009 basically they said scaling below
35 nanometers is challenging and they
were actually right in my opinion
because of what I'll describe next
except we're clearly below 35 nanometers
today the DRM manufacturers are actually
manufacturing chips at 20 nanometers and
below but it's clearly it's it's clear
that it's challenging when you reduce
the size of the circuit both of these
properties reliability properties and
the retention property is difficult
become difficult much more difficult to
maintain so let me give you an example
from the field that my students and I
have found out and reported in the syska
paper
the idea is this is a rope hammer
problem basically if you take a DM chip
that's manufactured after 2010 maybe for
2015 and if you actually do what I'm
going to describe to that chip you'll
get errors in the chip and the idea is
you can activate a row open arrow and
then by applying high voltage to the
word line and then you can close the row
by pre charging that word line basically
go back to the lower voltage and if you
keep doing this enough times toggling
the word line enough times within a
refresh interval you get errors in
adjacent rows
now this called the row hammer problem
and this is actually a disturbance area
basically it's a very fundamental to any
type of memory that scales down to
smaller notes you're basically by
applying high voltage over here you're
accelerating the charge leakage on some
of the weak cells that that are due to
the word line to word line coupling that
are in the adjacent row but they have
nothing to do with this row over here
and we call this the hammered row and we
call these the victim rows and basically
we've shown that you can this is a
failure mechanism that is that I've
escaped and that you can get exposed as
a user in the field if you have the D um
chips and what fraction of the DRAM
chips are vulnerable among the ones
we've tested from three different
manufacturers more than 80 percent
exhibit this error and you can actually
write a simple program a seven line user
level program which we published at
github so you can download then you can
test on your laptops as we go through
this talk that's what this program does
is it exercises that by bypassing the
caches and the selecting address is x
and y such that they map to the same
bank and basically ping-ponging we
activate some pre charges across those
as a result of your vulnerable chip you
get some errors and using this program
you can actually see that existing
systems are vulnerable if they have the
DRAM chip that exhibits the failure
mechanism and a more control it's a real
reliability and security sham we'll talk
about why it's a security in a little
bit but in a more controlled environment
you can actually induce a lot more
errors than what we've seen over here
and clearly
the errors correlates with the access
rates because you need to do it enough
time such that you accelerate the charge
leakage and drain the capacitors such
that before it gets refreshed so one
solution you can think of right now is
you can actually refresh the UM more
more frequently to get rid of these
errors and that's actually a viable
solution except the results that we have
in this paper suggest that if you want
to get rid of all of the errors you need
to refresh the UM by seven times more at
a faster rate okay so why is this a
scaling problem clearly this happens
because you have word-line too we have
interference between different cells and
as you scale the circuit down that
interference becomes higher so we test
the chips from 2008 to 2014 I know even
2015 right now it's not shown here the
first time error appears in the chips
that were manufactured in 2010 before
that there are no errors later between
2012 and 2013 the air manufacturers were
not able to contain these errors and for
good reason because this requires a lot
of testing if you can imagine what the
testing goes into it and all of the all
of the chips that were manufactured
during this period are actually
vulnerable and later manufactures start
realizing it and actually they have
mechanisms to fix these errors and we
have this infrastructure where we tested
DRM but this is the old version of the
interest it's the oldest version of the
infrastructure and we have a newer
version but I'll talk about some of
these other works that I actually that
we used to derive some insights into
into DM scaling and this is the latest
version of the infrastructure I'd be
happy to talk about this and we're
hoping that we'll put it into public use
by expanding the memory controllers out
there but the paper has a lot of results
so one interesting solution one
interesting part of it is what is the
solution space you can imagine many many
solutions to this error correcting codes
could be one of them
and the sect that actually doesn't
correct all of the errors according to
our results and the solution we propose
very briefly is involves refresh these
are the ideas if you access if you
activate a word line with very low
probability activate the word lines
around it such that you minimize the
risk of errors over over the long run
and by doing this you can actually get
reliable to guarantees that are much
better than hard desks today
memory vendors because isn't it true
that if you look at memory built in
self-test right back you know this
walking ones working zeros and all that
stuff physically that goes after
coupling cells and to combine that with
retention test physically they would be
caught right that's why so did you talk
to the interior vendors to see like why
no what was the motivation for letting
this test is not happening so maybe they
didn't realize that we have talked with
it I mean they don't tell us why the
errors happen clearly but I think there
are chemi tests that are designed but
they're very costly as you said right
and going forward it's going to be a big
problem testing these DMS
I think but later after we published
this past mark actually included a
hammer test in there in there mem test
86 program so you can actually have that
test it can run it on your real systems
and I believe going forward this kind of
failure mechanism will need to be tested
to screen it out but we'll talk about
the D I'm testing a little bit more
detail later on like by doing this thing
very somehow changing the specs of this
is not supposed to happen
in the year because you shouldn't sub
this a very predictable form of error I
should not get that so that's one of the
solutions that we've discussed how do
you detect whether you're being hammered
basically you need to keep track of the
number of hammerings that happen and
that actually costs a lot of hardware
I'd be happy to yeah it does cause we
describe that in the paper actually so
this probabilistic refresh doesn't cost
any hardware any state except you do it
randomly and the problem is you need to
know which rows are adjacent to this row
and today's memory controllers have no
exposure to that information yeah so you
can do it with indium if you have slack
in the timing but it's very difficult to
do it on the memory controller side
that's why I think we need some other
interface to fix some of these issues
okay so we can talk about solutions
fascinating actually to talk about the
solutions but I'd love
one thing I will talk about is this is
actually seems like a little hardware
problem but it actually affects a lot of
the system security that we have built
things upon basically me wrote the paper
the first sentence we had about memory
isolations a key property of a reliable
and secure computing system and access
to one memory address should not have
unintended side effects on data stored
in other addresses I mean you are pretty
sure that you could design an attack to
take or an entire system and that's
exactly what Google project 0 did in
March of this year what they did was
they exploited this bug to gain kernel
privileges and I'll copy from their blog
post basically it's for this slide they
test the selection of laptops and they
found that it's vulnerable to this
problem and they built two different
privilege escalation exploits that use
this and you can read it in more detail
but the cool thing is what they did was
they were able to induce bit flips in
their page tape as a user level process
and the page table entries and you can
actually induce a bit foot in your
write-protect bit or write enable a bit
that actually points your own page table
as a result you gain write access to
your own page table which means that you
can write access to your entire physical
memory that's how they were able to take
over 50% of laptops and recently there
was some research coming out of Europe
where they showed that you could
actually use the JavaScript to execute
code remotely on some other computer
that's well nerble throughout hammer bog
and you can take over that computer
remotely so it's pretty interesting
actually and later this became a kind of
popular and they people came up with
funny pictures like this and one of the
quotes that I really liked on the
website which really I think provides
the insight to the security attack if
you want to gain access to that door
we're there you keep hammering on the
story enough times and that door opens
up and then you're getting privileged
access to that door ok so let me recap
the DRAM scaling problem so I believe
this is one evidence of the DM scaling
problem and if you think about if you
take a step back there's nothing new
here right all of the memories that they
scale down they have these effects flash
memory for example is very prone to read
disturb errors and flash memory has a
controller that corrects those are in in
in hard disks you have adjacent track
interference and there is a controller
that fixes a lot of those issues but
indium we weren't
used to these issues getting exposed so
we need some solution but before that
let me talk about one paper that Samsung
and Intel two unlikely partners to write
papers together they've written this
paper in the memory form 2014 that we've
organized with iske and they've pointed
out some of the challenges which I will
talk about later and they identify
refresh as a big challenge and variable
retention time is a big challenge we'll
talk about this in a little bit but it's
clear that the manufacturers are also
seeing the problem and the solution
they've described is similar to what has
been employed in other memories basic
core architecting controllers and DM
together such that because the process
or the device is not scaling we're about
maybe you punt a little bit and thus it
you enable the system to scale by Co
designing the system and the DM together
so that brings me how do we solve the
problem I'll talk about three the
solution directions overall and then
we'll go into a bit more detail so the
first solution is making DM and
controllers more intelligent fixing it
basically since we cannot fix it well
maybe we can fix it at the device stile
and circuit though I'm not precluding
that possibility but I think a good
direction to explore is to design the
system together with the DM looking at
new interfaces new functions and new
architectures the second solution
direction which is also promising in my
opinion is somehow trying to eliminate
or minimize the problem is it could come
up with a scalable technology that's
much better than here and that doesn't
have these issues good luck with that
but I think this is really interesting
to explore basically this can open up
new technologies and system-wide
rethinking of storage and memory
depending on what kind of technologies
you actually design and the third
solution reaction which may sound a
little bit crazy sometimes is to embrace
it maybe maybe we can design some
memories to be not reliable and design
take advantage of the application level
characteristics and make use of these
lemon memories and I think that's really
interesting too because this can open up
new models for data management and maybe
usage as long as we can do it
appropriately and there may be other
solution directions but I think
regardless of the solution direction you
take good solutions to memory scaling in
the end will require software hardware
and device cooperation especially given
that historical examples we have in
other memories so we need to some
rethinking across the stack so let me
very quickly talk about these solution
directions and I'll talk about an
orthogonal problem and then we'll go
- solution directions so what do I mean
by fixing Giambi school you'd like to
overcome the shortcomings that we have
in the technology with what I call
system dear I'm co.design this is not
this can open up new GM architectures
interface them functions and the good
thing is industry is actually interested
in doing something around this area that
has not been the case traditionally in
memory industry and we should do better
waste management more efficient
utilization since the resource is not
scaling very well so there are several
key issues to tackle I'll touch on some
of them during the seminar one is
enabling reliable T at low cost fixing
problems like grow hammer and we'll talk
about that a little bit the second is
reducing energy such that we can scale
the memory and these are actually two
sides of the same coin if you think
about it you can enable more reliability
by expending more energy in fact apple
solution to the RO hammer problem the
Apple released a security patch after
after we've written our paper and group
after Google's attack what they in the
security patch what they've said on the
web is they increase the refresh rate to
actually fix the roll camera problem -
the problem is if as you increase the
refresh rate you increase your energy
even though your enable reliable so
these are really two sides of the same
coin
and improving latency and bandwidth is
important I'm not sure if I'll get to
talk about this but especially reducing
latency there's a lot we can do in this
area and um because we're really wasting
a lot of latency our timing parameters
are for the design for the worst case
and reducing waste in capacity bandwidth
and latency that's I think very
promising also one thing that I will
focus on that can help a lot and whose
an idea whose time may have may come if
we design if you do the right things is
enabling computation close to data
because we can actually potentially fix
a lot of the issues we're having if we
do this over here we don't not we not
only can enable computation but also
management close to the data so I'll
talk about some of the works that we
have in this area the second solution
direction is the emerging memory take
neither some emerging resistive memory
technologies and because they're
resistive they're more skilled because
they're not dependent on this charge
storage and as a result and they're also
non-volatile one example is phase change
memory there also other examples DTM Ram
RM resistor Ram and these are expect to
scale to much smaller nanometers and I
TS has been project
that nine nanometers at the same time it
was projecting 35 nanometers hard for ya
and they expect to be denser than the
air and because these technologies can
store multiple bits per cell by chopping
up the resistance range just like flash
chops up the voltage range the problem
is a lot of these technologies have many
shortcomings the key question we are
asking is can we somehow enable them to
replace augment or maybe surpassed yeah
if you and I'll talk about some of the
works in this area I think this is also
very promising direction the third
solution direction which I will also
talk about is doing something that looks
like this it's this a cartoonish picture
don't take it so seriously because it
could be designed a different way about
designing hybrid memory systems people
have searched for universal memory for a
long time
Universal memory is a memory that's good
oh and with green in all metrics but if
we don't have green in all metrics if
you have some memories that are green at
some things and red at some other things
but in other memories that are green at
some other things and red at some other
things yet other things maybe we can
combine them together somehow and design
the hardware and the software together
to manage the data allocation and
movements to achieve the best of
multiple technologies I think this is a
very promising direction going forward
you can actually have the ERM of
different types as well to be able to do
that let me give you one very quick
example this is just as a teaser if you
will but one of the promising directions
in my opinion is to exploit application
level fault tolerance if you understand
your application very well you can
potentially mark your data or understand
your data based on its memory area
vulnerable so if you inject a bit flip
to that portion of your data space
sometimes it doesn't matter that much
because your application doesn't crash
maybe a pixel changes maybe no one cares
and the end but sometimes it matters a
lot maybe you change a pointer in your
programming your index of the database
and that actually crashes the entire
system so if you can somehow classify
your data as vulnerable and tolerant you
can perhaps take advantage of this at
the memory level design reliable versus
low-cost memories maybe you don't care
about the row hammer folds as much over
here and you can actually take advantage
of this so we actually have a case study
of this with Microsoft's web search
workload in all our data centers the ECC
memory is used so that you can protect
for the errors
but this way you can get rid of a lot of
the cost in memory by making some of
your memory low-cost that way you can
reduce the hardware cost reasonably
while still achieving a reasonable
single server availability target so I
think this is one just one example
that's just scratching the surface one
example of a heterogeneous memory in
this case it's heterogeneous in terms of
reliability but you can imagine
heterogeneity in terms of different
technologies as well and this was all
done manually by Gemma manually
modifying the application it doesn't
work for all application so if you
actually do it for graph processing
applications it's actually very
difficult unless you go very fine-grain
in the data structures okay let me
briefly talk about an orthogonal issue
and I'll talk about more specific
solution ideas and this orthogonal issue
is really important in my I think that's
why I don't want to remove these slides
and the problem is you have this memory
bus that's shared and the cores
interfere with this memory bus when they
access the shared main memory and that's
an interference problem if you don't
somehow control the interference which
is actually the case in most systems
today you can actually get an well
nerble system basically the memory
controller can be optimizing for
locality in the row buffer zone main
memory and an application may be very
good at exploiting that locality as a
result this application that is doing
random access that has bad locality will
be deprioritized by the memory
controller if your memory controller
policy is to optimize for locality
without being application aware and as a
result if you have unfair policies you
can have an uncontrollable unpredictable
and vulnerable system and this becomes
more important if you're running many
more applications on top of on your note
where you're sharing the memory bus so
how do you actually fix this problem
we've been looking at this I'd love to
talk about this with other people but
very quickly you need to design a
quality of service of our memory system
where the hardware provides at least
some sort of guarantees it provides a
configurable fairness substrate
application of our memory scheduling
policies ability to partition memory
awareness of the memory to the higher
levels and throttling mechanism such
that you don't overload your memory and
software can be designed to configure
these resources to satisfy different
quality of service goals so it's a
hardware software cooperative problem
and this problem is going to be even
more important because we're designing
even more
complex systems basically we have not
only course but GPUs and hardware
accelerators they all have different
demands from the system and they all
share different parts of the memory
system and the memory is also getting
more complex basically we have hybrid
memories and hybrid memory controllers
that are controlling them the key
question we're asking is how do you
allocate the resources in the memory
system to these heterogeneous agents to
mitigate the interference that's
happening across these different agents
well and provide predict provide
predictable performance to those agents
that actually need that performance so
one solution Direction very quickly this
is my last slide on the quality of
service I think we've been looking at
more best effort approaches but I think
going forward strong memory service
guarantees is really important and the
way we're thinking about the problem
currently is if we can somehow estimate
the performance loss you have or slow
down you have for an agent when you're
running together with other agents and
if you have an online model that can
estimate this accurately you can
actually use this in many ways at the
system level you can expose this to the
operating system for example the
operating system now has a very good
idea of over this application is slowing
down a lot because it's sharing memory
resources with the other application and
if you design the mechanisms resource
partitioning mechanism or prioritization
mechanisms in the caches and the
interconnect and the hardware you can
actually use these models to drive the
partitioning such that you satisfy the
performance requirements of a given
application you can now say oh this
application shouldn't be slowed down by
2x regardless of whatever I run it with
and if you have this model and the model
is accurate you can try to satisfy that
and if you cannot satisfy that then you
punt the problem to the higher workload
schedule and the workload scheduler does
something else today we don't have this
guarantee from a single node as a result
I think we're under utilizing the single
nodes a lot because if we want to
provide these guarantees we want to be
we need to be conservative because
hardware doesn't provide any guarantees
underneath now it's changing in the cash
level Intel actually has in has well the
quality of service mechanism such that
you can partition the cache but going
forward we need to look deeper into the
memory of course you need to do this all
the while providing high system
performance this goes without saying
because fairness or quality of service
is not a problem
if you don't care about performance you
can design a thousand four thousand
agent system and just run one agent on
the system and everything else becomes
underutilized
so I'm not going to talk about this but
we are mechanism that's coming up it'll
be published in micro in December that
talks about an application slowdown
model that achieves about 10% error an
area of within 10% to do the slowdown
estimation in caches and main memory
okay any questions so far
am i speaking too fast okay cool oh now
we can actually I can increase my speed
and you can throttle me back really I
don't think fresh takes a heck of a lot
of energy it seems like so yeah it
depends on the solution so refresh I
agree today it may not take a lot of
energy but going forward we'll talk
about it it will take more energy so
it's not a scalable solution going
forward but it's a probably a good
stopgap solution for today and I don't
know how much they increase the refresh
rate they don't talk about that in that
web post maybe 2x that's my guess but
maybe 4x also but 2x in our in our
experiments 2x actually doesn't get rid
of all the airs increasing refresh but I
think a targeted refresh more
probabilistic refresh actually is very
negligible in terms of energy and
performance yes I'll talk about some of
those here yeah basically the first part
I will dedicate to new memory
architectures I'll talk about rethinking
DM we have a lot of work in rethinking
flash memory also we have a very similar
infrastructure for flash memory where we
gained a lot of insights thanks to some
of our industrial partners but I'm not
going to talk about that but in a little
bit the second direction is enabling
emerging memory technology so I'll
dedicate some time on hybrid memory
systems and single level memory and
storage so back to the future
maybe a little bit but I'm not going to
talk about the system level memory and
storage quality officers although that's
a critical problem but we just don't
have time so hopefully at the end of
this talk you'll have a lot of hope that
we will fix the UM somehow but will also
enable these emerging memory technology
somehow and maybe design a predictable
system let me jump into the first one
there's a lot to talk about dear I'm
actually we've been focusing on this for
the past four or five years and I'll
probably cover these these three very
quickly well not very quickly but these
three let me start with in-memory
computation because I think this an idea
whose time has come and why do I think
it was its time has come because we're
feeling this technology push from the UM
the I'm scaling is very difficult right
now and take the vendors are very
interested in examining new solution
directions for example the the paper
that I mentioned from Samsung and Intel
one of the solutions that they propose
is putting ECC inside the um in the um
ECC this was a big no-no for vendors for
a long time you don't want to modify the
sub-race because that has a lot of
overhead but now they're thinking of
putting ECC because they're feeling the
heat so if you actually can do things
like that if you can put a logic layer
underneath um which some vendors have
explored like hybrid memory cube then we
can perhaps explore even more
interesting solutions that can change
the model of execution that we have
today and the second is in no time in
the system in the system design we have
we've had in the decades we were so
pressed by data movements and data
movement and storage being a bottleneck
so far basically systems our energy
limited data moment is the biggest cost
and applications are extremely data
intensive both bandwidth and capacity so
there's this application push also
that's driving us to do more on the
memory side in my opinion and I'll talk
about two approaches and this is a
really old idea that one of the in the
in the late 1960s Harold stone from IBM
Research actually he published the first
paper logic and memory and at that time
that's in 1970 at that time the idea was
if you can put processors inside DRM we
can do a lot more I'm not going to talk
about that I think that's going to be
very difficult even though that some of
those early works were really
interesting I think we should think a
little bit differently perhaps today and
one approach that has a lot of promise
and surprising it hasn't been examined
as much as minimally changing the app I
think we can minimally change the UM to
enable simple yet powerful computation
primitives they can be limited but the
arm can be used as an accelerator
especially when you need it
significantly so I'll talk about the
syllabus and the second solution
direction which I will not talk about
to exploit the lock control logic in the
3d stacked memory which hopefully will
exist such that you can enable more
comprehensive computation near memory so
this may be a more costly approach so
let me first focus on the first one but
I'll talk very little if we have time at
the end of the in memory computation
part so what do I mean by minimally
changing the app so this is when we
first started we were thinking about
what is minimal changes
what is the I'm good at what can we do
that we can provide and the first thing
is you can imagine as both data copy
actually if we can do copying internally
in the DRAM chip we can save a lot of
energy now granted this is cheating
that's not computation but even that's
not possible today so let's talk about
the problem first if you want to copy
one page to another in memory today we
go through the CPU as intermediary
basically to bring the source page byte
by byte all the way into l1 the
destination page byte by byte all the
way into the l1 do the copy and write
the destination page all the way back
into memory now with a 4 kilobyte this
is still bad but if you think it
considered one you go back page that's
actually overwhelms the system now you
don't mind hopefully you're not doing
copies with one gear by pages but that
could happen actually there
initialization actually you
initialization is a very special form of
copy and initialization can consume a
lot of cycles but this is high latency
because you do round trips across this
most important system resource perhaps
this consumes high bandwidth on the data
bus this cause cache pollution but you
could eliminate that through the DMA
engine perhaps this cause unwanted data
moment especially if you're not using
the destination page at all soon
basically if you want to do this copy
with the ddr3 technology for a four
kilobyte page through the DMA engine
without taking take onto overheads of
setting up and tearing down the DMA
basically it takes a thousand 46
nanoseconds and 3.6 micro joules now
wouldn't it be nice if we had the option
in the system to tell the memory to do
this and the memory doesn't bother
anyone else this would be low latency
because I'm going to give you a
mechanism multiple mechanisms actually
this will cause no bandwidth utilization
on the date of us which is a major
bottleneck this would cause no cache
pollution but you could eliminate that
if you want today and this causes no
unwanted data moment so it saves energy
and I'm going to show you a mechanism
which in the best case reduces us at
46 nanoseconds for a 4 kilobyte copy 299
seconds and the 3.6 micro joules - 0.04
micro joules and the idea is actually
really simple if you know about how diem
operates in the subway level this is the
da I'm sorry if you want to read one
byte over here or eight bits over here
you really need to activate an entire
row and that drove let's say it's the
same as page size four kilobyte you can
activate this row and then you take a
read command to read the entire you know
eight bits out of the straw buffer so
we're going to take advantage of this
role of location to the row clone the
idea is if you want to copy one source
page to a destination page EDDM first
you activate the source row which brings
the data into the sense amplifiers then
you send a command that deactivates the
source row but activates the destination
row and once you do do that the data and
the sense amplifiers actually start
driving the destination cells as a
result you've used the sense amplifiers
as an intermediary to do the copy
basically by doing two consecutive
activates you can do this copy really
fast as long as the source and
destination rows share the sense
amplifiers which means that they are in
the same sub array and you cannot do
this in today's DM chips unfortunately
because it's not enabled but this is
very very little cost to do because
there's a DRM no memory built in
self-test we can take advantage of the
ng maybe just simply read it because the
this controller should be able to read
and write write so they already have the
registers and you said I think the
circuitry actually goes outside the
subway so if you can't you can do it
actually I agree
it'll be slower than this yeah
absolutely yes absolutely and this the
other solutions are going to resemble
that yeah I agree with you certainly so
this is the fastest you can get I think
in the subarrays and it's actually
ninety nights like this two consecutive
activates well I had modified the slide
but that's not 0.01 percent area caused
by the 0.01 percent comes from
generalizing it such that the data such
that you can do it in the entire within
the chip so clearly this is not general
because it's limited the sub-race and
actually
rating system has no visibility to the
sub race that's but we'll talk about
that so interests are very copy is just
to activates but we would like to do it
even if the data resides in different
tanks so what we do is to have pipelines
internal reading right through the data
bus internally in the DM basically you
have you set one bank to read mode to
set the other bank to write mode and you
can do arbitrary length data copies by
doing this and the hardest part which
I'm not going to talk about where you
can actually utilize the best circuitry
is if you want to copy data from one
page over here in one sorry to another
page in another sorry in the same Bank
because they share the global bit lines
you cannot do that as fast as this so we
act what we actually do is we use
interbank copy twice but you could
actually use the bit circuitry also so
all of this is 0.01 percent area cost
with our models of the UN so what is the
savings you get clearly the savings you
get depend on where the source and
destination pages are and hopefully if
you expose the system the system can
allocate the pages such that you get the
maximal savings that's one of the things
that I will talk about in a little bit
but basically if the source and
destination are in the same sub Rea you
get 11 11 times
latency reduction and the energy
reduction is the DM energy only it's 74
X because you're not exercising that
interconnect between DM n memory and
clearly if it's between different banks
you save less energy and less latency
but still you gain the worst case you
still save energy
internally so what is the impact on the
application performance these are
probably not the best applications I
take all these with a grain of salt but
basically it improves performance fork
for example is the poster child for this
because it does a lot of copy-on-write
in the end and if you're able to
allocate so one thing if you if you're
doing copy on writes in the operating
system and the operating system as
visibility to the DM topology into the
sub race the operating system can say or
when I'm writing to this page I need to
do a copy at that point I'm going to
allocate that page from the same sub
array as the source page today we don't
have that visibility we really need
interfaces that are much better into
memory such that we can do this kind of
system level optimizations so if you do
that actually can gain a lot of
performance and the papers a lot of
analysis so system boot-up for example
you can gain a lot of performance
basically the performance improvement
score improvements correlate with the
amount of
copying an initialization that you do so
initialization is something that I very
briefly touched on initialization is
really a special form of copy basically
you want to zero initialize a huge chunk
of memory you zero initialize a row and
then copy that drove to other roles that
way you can actually get rid of a lot of
the initialization penalty too and the
performance improvement is even more in
multi-core systems because one when one
application or one thread is doing
copies you're freeing up the memory bus
such that the other thread can actually
access memory so let's say let's assume
that we had this role Cohen idea and I
think the eye manufactures are really
interested in small changes like this
that can actually impact a lot of
applications we still are not done
clearly right you really need to have an
end-to-end system designed to take
advantage of something like this and
this is true for all in memory
computation that I'm going to talk about
but I'll use Rockland as an example we
have this roeckl enabled DM how do you
take advantage of it
first you definitely need to communicate
occurrences of this bulk copy
initialization or actually it doesn't
have to be both copy if you're doing
interbank it has to be bucket if you're
doing somebody across the layers so you
tab mechanisms where this fortunately
summer I say is actually have this today
the excited to have the repeat
instructive X which you can use with
copying instructions ensuring cache
coherence is critical and we have some
mechanism for that that I'm not going to
talk about especially if you want to use
this in the general-purpose domain and
the special purpose domains for perhaps
you can ignore some of this early on but
going forward to we need better
mechanisms because this can actually
dominate the costs of doing computation
and memory how do you maximize latency
and energy savings so how do you make
the operating system and the
applications aware of the topology of
the DM and the computation capability
such that you can get the best
advantages as I've described if you make
the operating system aware of the subway
or the DM topology you can get a lot
more done and finally we don't want to
do this always in memory in fact if you
do ro clone for all page copies you lose
performance in some applications
sometimes you do want to do this on the
processor side especially when you're
caching is very effective so we want to
have mechanisms to understand when to do
what
sometimes row clones sometimes doing the
copy internally in the processor so
that's also very important and the paper
has some detail related to that so where
are we taking this I think we're
designing all these differ
accelerators that are very good at
making us process data efficiently but
basically I think this direction is
really thinking of memory as a command
is similar to a conventional accelerator
memory is good at some things if we can
figure out what those some things are we
can put some specialized compute
capability in memory and we can think of
that as an accelerator for those
computations it's actually a very
different exciter from what we have here
because it has access to this huge data
store and it's also sitting on the other
side of the memory bus all these
actuators are bound by the memory bus if
you're dealing with huge data so one of
the things that I will briefly touch
upon this is something we deal with in
one of the iske papers with 3d stack
memory but it's a general problem if we
can somehow enable in-memory search or
graph analytics or big data analytics I
don't like using that big data term but
big data analytics how can we do it I'm
going to list a lot of questions over
here but iske baare iske paper has some
answers basically let's say you have
this data base or graph stored in memory
in your different sub arrays we'd like
to send a query to memory with some
interface over here and the memory does
the searching in its sub arrays and
returns back the result such that the
CPU can focus on this there are many
questions here is the interfaces that we
have today do not enable this means more
scalable and flexible interfaces what is
the right partitioning of computation
capability what is the right low cost
memory substrates how do you actually
build this compares I just gave you a
copy right hopefully I'll give you a
little bit more hope in the next few
slides but you need to do more than just
copy if you have the logic there inside
3d stack 3d stack then you can actually
do more and that's what our iske paper
is about you can actually gain 14x
performance improvement and reduce any
memory system energy by 10x if you have
a graph analytics engine that's sitting
in an interconnected set of 3d stats I'm
not going to talk about that that's the
more more intrusive approach because you
need a different programming model to
take advantage of that actually so what
maybe technology Stan a blurs DRM it's
very interesting to examine but there
are other technologies that integrate
much better with logic and once we have
this how the actually rethink or ease
search algorithms or different
algorithms and applications in fact we
have this problem with row clone we were
actually searching for applications and
when we talked with people they say oh
we
those copies as much as possible so they
actually jumped through hoops in their
software such that they don't exercise a
lot copies as there is not this
complicated software a lot actually but
if the copies are a lot cheaper maybe
there's a different way of designing the
software which makes life easier for the
programmers and that's true for other
computations also I believe this
actually slide from my students we've
excess shadi who developed the idea of
ro clone but basically we need support
across the entire system this is from
his proposal and he's completed all all
of this so he's ready to graduate I
believe but the blue parts yeah but
basically the we have a paper coming up
on India I'm gather scatter and I'll
hopefully give you some hope by talking
about Indian bitwise operations but we
need cache coherence support and we also
need some virtual memory support that
I'm not going to talk about but let me
give you a little bit more hope because
computation is data moment is kind of
cheating because you don't do any
computation but I think there's a lot of
potential for computation in DM also
even within the core of the subarray I
think external part like the best part
is very interesting also to examine but
in the core you can get even more
benefits and the idea is how do we do in
and and or and I'm going to assume an
idealized circuit here basically if you
have these ABC rows ABC and if you can
currently connect the word lines to the
bit line what you really get is a
majority circuit of a B and C now you
can actually do a majority circuit
operation and the entire ABC rows but
the other interesting thing is you can
rewrite this equation like this you can
take out C and now this can be your
control row if C is set to one or once
now you get the or of a and B if C is
set to all zeros you get the end of a
and B basically we have an analog
computation mechanism that can do and
then or in the UM assuming you can
design these really nicely of course its
destructive absolutely yeah so I'm going
to give you the instruction semantics in
a little bit it destroys in the end the
results get result becomes whatever you
have over here so you can actually
imagine an instruction that looks like
bulk and which is semantics are like
that and this is one way of implementing
it
can reserve a row to zero is there
another road to one and you can have
designated gross for triple activations
so the cost of this is triple activation
and you want to limit that because you
don't want to be able to do triple
activation in arbitrary addresses in the
sub race so if you actually reserved
this to a very small portion you can
actually do the end and/or in that small
portion in the subway and this is how it
works basically instruction you first
roll clone the data into this designated
one row row clone B into the designated
two row row clone r0 which is the end in
this case you need the controller all
into d3 you activate through the triple
activate and then roll clone the results
into C and now d1 d2 and d3 have all all
have the result so if you do this what
are the benefits you get basically we
see significant improvements in end and
or throughput compared to the
state-of-the-art mechanism which is
doing the doing the end and or inside
the sim D units Intel AVX over here and
so Intel ABX actually works really well
this is the size of the vectors to end
or or and this is the throughput of the
end operations in this case if your
vectors are really small you run out of
the cache so your sim D units are very
effective actually you get very high
throughput but if your vectors are
really large the throughput of the
similar units reduces because now your
memory bound whereas if you're doing
this operation in memory you can sustain
the same level of throughput which is
actually 20x higher in this case when
your vectors are larger and you can
actually scale this by doing in many
banks at the same time as your data size
scales we can actually do it and
currently in many banks and the energy
reduction is significant and the state
paper has a more detail actually you get
50x energy reduction because you're not
moving data out of the chip so we've
actually tested this on some real
workloads a database that does range
queries that uses a lot of ands and ORS
to actually do the selection and it uses
the fast bit library which is a very
fast library that we're doing and in
ours we ported that library to use this
in our simulator and you can see a
significant performance improvements and
many range queries and the paper has a
lot more detail on this yes variation
control so this is exactly why I said
assume an idealized circuit
so I think if you if you if you reserved
three designated rows I believe it could
be designed but then I think that's up
to the UM designers that's that's a
that's a part where I can I cannot
design it but I believe that good D um
designers will be able to sign it yes
the alignment issues within the the bus
so that's one question that's the
limitation of this model basically your
data you cop you UN Dan or everything
over here but we're developing more
primitives like knots or some X or or
masking that we can do potentially in
memory but I don't have those results
yet you need to do so I think the
benefits are similar to the roll call
benefits that we have not period
actually exploring that right now but
benefits are even you remember the
interbank copy I think the benefits are
similar to that exactly it solved that
order so it's still significant but it's
not 20x yes so these are some range
queries in a database in that uses the
fast bit library I don't remember the
exact thing but the paper has the
details
and I can send you more information this
is a shorter version of the paper
version who is
some question that's the next step
exactly exactly
you'll become Willie and complete
basically right yeah so that's our goal
actually basically we're we're taking
this we want the ball computation model
in memory we have some mechanisms to the
inversion it's not as easy as and an or
but there are different ways of thinking
about it and doing it but maybe I'll
talk about that later at some point but
I think this is very interesting maybe
bulk maybe I should put the ball in
parenthesis because as Sebastian
mentioned there could be other ways of
doing the computation internally in chip
but this could this basically requires
new memory and software interfaces to
enable in-memory computation and at some
point I think I'd love to examine new
programming models algorithms and
compilers perhaps because this can
actually if you have a ball computation
model in memory you can actually take
advantage of a lot of things in my
opinion so I've talked about the first
approach weights the minimally changing
the um table simple yet powerful
computation primitives and hopefully
giving you some hope in that direction
there's a lot more you can do with the
3d stacked control logic layer and I'll
point you to these papers basically
we've examined what is the minimum thing
that you can do if you have a 3d stacked
logic layer without changing the
existing programming model keeping the
sequential programming model without
changing the virtual memory substrate
without changing the cache coherence
mechanism significantly and we call it
the PIM enabled instructions basically
you have an instruction come at you can
execute in memory or in the processor
and it's virtualized its cache coherence
and that actually buys you some benefit
and this was a second thing that we've
explored that's also published at iske
basically the ideas what is the thing
that you can do if you can change things
maximally in this case you can think of
it think of the the 3d stack memory as
an accelerator how do you map the graph
processing application to it what is the
programming model we don't assume
virtual memory in this case for example
so that's that actually shows a lot of
benefits also that I mentioned earlier I
don't have time to talk about this but I
think this is a very promising direction
as well okay let me jump in to refresh
and then I'll switch to the other
direction which is emerging memory
technologies how much time do we have
left
Oh 17 minutes okay refresh we'll be
really quick done okay
I want to talk about refresh because
this is one of the major skins if you
talk to DM designer probably they will
tell you that this is the biggest
headache they have India but the problem
is neon capacitor charge leaks over time
and the memory Couture needs to refresh
each job periodically restore the charge
and today you need to refresh every
activate area of any meal is like every
and milliseconds typically Ines
sixty-four milliseconds that's probably
going to go down there many downside to
this energy performance quality of
service impact but I'll talk about one
thing refresh rate actual limits DM
capacity scaling so this is from a paper
that we did in iske in 2012 this is
device capacity on the x-axis this is
the percentage of time you have to spend
to the Refresh base of throughput loss
of the device due to refresh today it's
about eight percent if the scaling trend
continues and I do have to talk about
the assumptions that go into this it's
going to be about 50 percent if you
design a 64 Giga bit um chip and energy
percentage of VI minor is spent
refreshing today it's about 15 percent
let's say and again you can argue with
the numbers depending on your
utilization and how much you're
accessing in memory this changes but
with the same utilization at 64 Giga bit
note you'll be spending 50% of your DM
energy on refresh if nothing changes and
this is a bit scary because we're
designing this huge memory chip which we
cannot access elf all the time and help
of its power is really energy is spent
on refresh keeping the data I'll talk
about one promising direction I'll talk
about the issues related to this
basically we don't need to design the
Refresh for the worst case if you look
at the retention time of profile of DM
due to the variation in the circuit you
have this retention time profile today
we're refreshing everything every 64
milliseconds but most of memory doesn't
need to be refreshed for 256
milliseconds so if you can somehow
figure this out you can actually reduce
your refresh rate by 75% or a number of
refresh is by 75% and that's the ID I'll
give you some results first I'll talk
about one of the challenges in enabling
this and this in this an old observation
many people have written papers and
electron device letters but we've with
our infrastructure we've shown that this
actually holds true for many many drm
chips also the idea we've looked at is
three flashing rows containing weak
cells more frequently and other
less frequently and this requires three
steps very quickly you need to profile
the retains time of all rows figure out
the minimum retention time of all rows
and store the rows into bins by a
retention time in the memory controller
if you're doing this in the memory
controller and you can have really
simple mechanisms by using bloom filters
to do that I'll refer you to the paper
and the memory Couture can now refresh
droves in different bins at different
rates and if you do that you can get
significant refresh reduction almost 75%
at very low hardware costs you can
reduce the dynamic and idle power
significantly and you can get
significant performance improvement
actually benefits increase with DM
capacity so energy reduction increases
to 50% at 64 gigabit not now
the most difficult part turns out to be
the profiling step and that's exactly
why dear manufacturers are having a
problem because it's profiling figuring
out the test like what is the minimum
retention time is very difficult and
it's difficult then I'll refer you to
especially this paper over here
but it's difficult to to the problem
that da that the four-page paper that I
mentioned from Samsung and Intel talked
about the variable retention time
problem it turns out dear I'm cell the
refresh for example first of all as data
dependence that's one issue it depends
on the data around you how much you need
to refresh this particular cell but it
also dependent is depend on a random
process basically for a long time a dram
cell can retain data for hundreds of
seconds and later on charge gets trapped
in the cell and your leakage access
rates significantly and your retention
time tanks to eight milliseconds so you
have this bimodal behavior and many of
you I'm cells so you need to test the
dear I'm cell long enough such that you
get to the minimum attention time states
which could be days and days and days
according to our results and this
actually getting worse with D am scaling
that's why VRT is one of the biggest
issues and that's exactly why the our
manufacturers are really interested in
putting in D I'm ECC error correction
codes today yeah that's a very well
studied and examined effects and refresh
rate you need to refresh more frequently
as temperature increases and that's
already employed actually in some the
technologies lpddr4 example okay so i'm
not going to talk about this promises
fascinating problem so how do you
actually solve this problem given that
you need to test yeah
for days and days one option to say oh
dear manufacturers figure this out I
think it's going to be very difficult to
actually do that and the thing that we
argue over here is more online profiling
of the system actually there's one other
reason why it's hard for the DI
manufactures do this actually impossible
for da manufactures in my opinion once
you solder the DRAM chip on your board
you expose it to a very high temperature
and that changes the retention time
profile and this is actually becoming
worse with the scaled smaller
technologies so the solution we're
pursuing and I don't have all the
answers is to do more online profiling
of DM in the field I think this can
actually fix a lot of the issues that we
have initially protect DM with ECC maybe
in DM ECC and over time while you're
running the system at boot up plus
during your during the execution your
periodic test parts of DRAM and do
optimizations you can adjust refresh
rate reduce ECU can determine the
latency characteristics of different
roles at just the latency you can
actually say look at data patterns if
you're storing zeros maybe you don't
need to refresh that row you can skip a
lot of refresh so you can actually do a
lot more optimization specialize it to
the computation that you're running if
you can enable something like this but
clearly if you would like to enable
something like this you need different
interfaces and all kinds of mechanisms
to keep the performance overhead and
energy overheads low but this is where
we're what you're looking into going
forward with the infrastructure that we
have so I'm going to skip the latency
part even though it's very exciting in
my opinion because of this graph we've
focused on capacity so much but the
latency is not improving but I do have
to talk about the solutions later on but
let me move into this one which is also
exciting that's hard to pick from
multiple exciting things but I'll pick
this one so let me talk about the second
solution direction which is enabling
emerging memory technologies and this is
actually very promising in my opinion
because there's some resistant memory
technology I see more scalable than
there one example is phase change memory
which you may have heard of basically
it's actually a really old technology
IDE it's used in the rewritable CDs
except we export something else the
optical reflectivity of the different
pages of the material and rewritable CDs
basically they change memory stores data
by changing the phase of material
chocolate glass and data is read by
detecting the material resistance and
recent advanced and the read devices
over here the
access devices basically has made made
it to be able to do this to detect the
resistance reliably as a result it's
become interesting in CD rewritable CDs
you basically shine light on on a cell
as a result you get different with
different optical reflectivities and now
you can detect zero one but that's a
very slow reading process clearly so you
want this other read device that can
detect the material distance and it's
activated scale to much smaller
nanometers its prototype that 20
nanometers install six-week to be denser
than the I'm the key quest the key
problem is these are many shortcomings
and this is just one example can we
enable them to replace augment or even
maybe surpassed yeah very quickly charge
memory is difficult to scale because if
it's difficult to place on control
charge and reliable sensing becomes
difficult as charge storage unit size
reduces this true and flash this trendy
am also whereas resistive memory
technologies do not rely on charge they
change memory you Jack turn to change
the material face and you detect
resistance of the face in sttm you
inject current to change the magnet
polarity and you detect resistance
compared to a reference magnet and a
memory stirs RM REM you inject current
to change the atomic structure and
resistance to determine by the item
distance so they have very different
mechanisms but in the end they're all
resistive I'll focus on fascia memory
because we've been looking at that for
much longer but I think other memory
technologies are very very promising
also so I'm I'm not going to take sides
on any technology I'm going to look at
the architecture and system level
effects so I don't know and I don't know
if it's real but my suspicion based on
all of the readings is its phase change
memory actually but I'm not sure give a
great presentation
they said the drop phase change memory I
went to rewrap myself it must be wrong
oh they didn't say okay I'd love to get
that link from you sometime please thank
you I appreciate it
okay so let's look at the architectural
aspects I think so the pros and cons of
the cons over diem depends on what
technology it is so face serum you get
hopefully better technology skill and
better capacity and cost in the long run
you get non volatility and you get low
idle power refresh problem goes away
which is actually nice that's the key
scaling problem with you the problem is
you have a higher read latencies and
write latency is higher active energy
for reads and writes
especially for writes and you get lower
endurance a cell basically dies after
some number of writes which is similar
to the flash and you have some other
reliable tissues write resistance drift
but the time scales are much higher than
refresh as far as we know today so it's
clearly challenging to enable patient's
memory as a replacement for diem we'd
like to mitigate the shortcomings and
find the right way to PlayStation Grammy
in the system very quickly I'll go over
our thinking over the years the sexiest
slide from 2008 when we first started
looking at this we ask the question how
should we organize patient memory based
main memory and our first idea was some
of some memory in the system will
domaine remain as DM some memory will be
PCM and in this case how do you
partition and migrate data between PCM
DM becomes a problem I'm going to talk
about that later on but we were more
aggressive at the time he wants to
examine the implications of this at
least in terms of performance and energy
to begin with so we wanted to look at
the pure PCM based main memory so we did
this study that was published in this Co
2009 that we're very surveyed four types
of patient memory across many different
device and circuit level conferences and
try to derive some parameters to use for
a facies memory that's at feature size
90 nanometers and that's actually a
harder task that said than done
because none of these papers agree with
each other if you look at it but we
derived some parameters that are
reasonable in my opinion I can never be
sure but these are the latest parameters
you have you're really looking at a
memory that's 4x slower in terms of
reads
compared en 12x slower compared to the
um in terms of writes this is the energy
increase writes consume 43 X higher
energy and endurance a cell dies after
10 to the 8 rights to it and SL dies
because you actually as you inject
current and increase the temperature
significant to melt the material 650
degrees Celsius
contacts the great as a result you have
this endurance problem but basically if
you take a system that uses the UM and
magically replace every single DRAM cell
with a fascia memory cell with those
properties without changing anything in
the system this is what you get for
these applications you get sixty percent
performance degradation you get hundred
twenty percent energy increase and your
memory dies after five hundred dollars
that's clearly you don't want this as
your main memory without doing some
modification so you can read this paper
we've developed some techniques for
buffering basically if you have this
kind of memory as your main memory you'd
like to do enough buffering such that
you don't access the memory or you
minimally access it and if you do that
your results become better twenty
percent performance degradation compared
to the energy becomes on par with diem
but take this with a grain of salt
all energy modeling is of course
difficult with an emerging technology an
average lifetime becomes five point six
years which is better but maybe that's
not what you want because you don't want
to be bound by the average right so I
think this is actually going to be
difficult with some memory technology
that looks like this using it as main
memory because worst-case lifetime is
actually much shorter you have no
guarantees you can actually have an
attack program that can kill your memory
intensive application see large
performance and energy degradation and
maybe even use optimistic PCM parameters
I don't know yet but I think going
forward this hybrid memory systems is a
very interesting solution reaction can
we somehow architect memory systems that
look like this or maybe have dims that
have multiple types of technologies
maybe our 3d stacks that are multiple
different types of technologies and
manage the data allocation and moment so
we've looked at this in the context of
DM and PCM very briefly I'll give you
results I'm not going to go over the
detail but the key idea is somehow
identify your data that's better to
place at DRAM and better to and identify
other data that's better to place at PCM
so what's better to place at DM latency
critical data and data and data you can
access as fast in PCM as in DM you would
like you don't want to waste your DM
space in it and if you have streaming
accesses actually you can keep them in
PCM because you can read out of the row
buffers and your bandwidth can be as
high as diagram if you have streaming
access in fact all you were doing is
what
all you're doing is streaming can have a
memory hierarchy that's composed of very
slow circuits like tape maybe and design
a lot of buffers in between such that
you can spin through but basically
that's the idea somehow you mark the
data in hardware in this case and you
replace the data intelligently so if you
do this you can't you're kind of in the
middle compared to if this is 16 goodbye
PCM performances 16 go by DM performance
this hybrid memory with intelligent data
management gets you kind of in the
middle so we're still not there yet so
there's a lot more Headroom to do
research in this area in my opinion so
I'm going to skip this but as TTM and we
examine STTR mem as part of your main
memory and the results actually are
better because the cons of sttm I'm
compared to a change memory at least at
this point in time is much better you
have higher right latency but you don't
have the read latency problem you don't
have the read energy problem and you
don't have the endurance problem and as
a result your performance loss is not as
high and your energy savings are much
higher and if you're interested you can
take a look at the paper but let me tell
you a little bit about other
opportunities and then circle back and
then we'll conclude I think it's a very
exciting area actually regardless of
whatever technology that's enabling some
of these emerging technologies really
important there are many opportunities
processing tightly coupled with memory
is could be more interesting with some
of these emerging technologies more
robust system designs can be enabled
because of the non volatility and you
can enable new applications because of
the non volatility adviser disable
access to persistent memory but I'll
talk about one thing that requires a
different way of thinking about systems
going back to the future as I mentioned
earlier merging of memory and storage
we've been designing systems that look
like this for a long time basically if
you have a two-level storage model and
that is evolved because volatile data is
present in this main memory and main
memory is really fast and we use a load
store interface to access that main
memory and that's heavily x-rayed and
hardware so that we don't actually waste
the latency and bandwidth provided by
this main memory but because this
persistent storage was really slow we
used a different interface to go through
and access it basically we have the file
system interface and you have operating
system and file system calls and you
manipulate the persistent data actually
inside this main memory so you do a lot
of copies back
come forth and do the translation so
this is maybe okay if you have a free
access time is milliseconds over here
but once you replace this with something
like phase change memory which is very
similar to DM over here the code the
interface over here becomes a huge
bottleneck and I'll show you some
results related to that so what we would
like to do is to unify the management as
much as possible such that we can
eliminate all that wasted work to locate
translate and transfer data and maybe
even more actually if you can actually
enable access to persistent data
directly from the programming language
maybe you can do even more and I believe
this will improve energy and performs
that I'll give you some results and this
may simplify the program model going
forward and this the person's memory
manager I'm going to skip this but
basically we're going to we want to
expose a load store interface manage
data placement and movement security and
a lot of other things now once you have
once your operating on data with a
single interface now you need to
actually have metadata to talk to
identify data so this needs to be
managed also and this is a cartoonish
picture of what we're trying to do you
have this person memory manager load
store accessible and you have a
heterogeneous area of devices and
basically can address all of them with a
single address space in fact I think
maybe it's more ambitious but you would
like to address every data in the world
maybe with a single address space
eventually but I'm not sure how if
that's going to be doable
so let me give you very quickly what
could be the benefits of this this is
one from one application that's in this
paper it's storage bound it's actually a
postmark it's a bad application but
that's okay it's a it's just a poster
child for this but there are a lot of
other applications over here basically
it's storage bound if you use hard disk
drives you waste a lot of time just
accessing the hard disk if you replace
the hard disk with something like
phase-change memory and still have dear
I'm in the system you get 24 X
performance improvement now this still
uses the two-level model if you actually
get rid of the UM and have just phase
change memory which is slower than the
um and have a single level interface you
get 5x more and we haven't even we've
gotten read oh dear I'm in the system if
you add DM and do much more intelligent
data management you can actually do even
more than this so basically we'd like to
get this additional point by the way the
the things are as not not as dramatic
because you have flash somewhere over
here which actually has a more smooth
transition but basically there's a lot
of performance left on the table because
of the interface we have because
software becomes a bottleneck these
memories and this is the energy
improvements that you can get so in the
last one minutes let me actually talk
about how come you do better I'm going
to circle back and derive some
principles I've talked about a lot of
ideas I've left off a lot of ideas but I
think there are three cross-cutting
principles in everything that I've
described and I think we're not
exploiting that in the system today and
one is if we want to scale memory we
definitely want better cooperation
between the devices and the system we
want to expose more information to the
upper layers like the or figure out that
information with the right interfaces in
the system like the different refresh
rates or different latencies that you
want to employ for different parts of
memory which I didn't talk about or
different types of memories and their
characteristics and for this we need
flexible interface for in-memory
computation we need flexible interfaces
and we want more information flowing
from top to the down like what we should
do in memory what what data should be
placed where and we don't have these
interface that the interface we have to
memory today including flash is pretty
bad it's actually a very dumb interface
that treats the memory as a storage
device that does nothing intelligent the
second is I'm the the next two will be
very well known in the processor design
domain I think better than worst case
design so memory has been ignored
perhaps that's why we're not doing
better than worst case design but we're
still optimizing lots of things for the
worst case refresh rates latencies and
other things also reliability parameters
but worst case should not really
determine the common case we're leaving
a lot of performance and energy on the
table and I didn't talk about this but
the with the right interface you can
actually get rid of 30% of your DRAM
read latency today because drm latencies
are dictated by the worst case operation
today 85 degrees celsius worst case
device and the third is the
heterogeneity in design again this is
very well known and process to bind
space that's why we have the
accelerators right but we're not doing
this as much in memory so heterogeneity
enables a more efficient
design because there's no
one-size-fits-all memory that's good at
every metric that can optimize what do
you want so we would like to specialize
and become asymmetric of course clearly
this adds more complexity but for
scaling it's probably a good idea and I
believe these principles are coupled if
you want to actually exploit
heterogeneity you need better interfaces
if you want to do better for skins
design you need hydrogen 80 and better
interfaces at the same time ok let me
quickly summarize basically I've talked
about memory scaling problems I believe
these are critical bottleneck for system
performance efficiency and usability in
fact the threatened system security as
I've described earlier I've talked about
new memory architectures I think there's
a lot of hope in fixing the UM enabling
emerging memory technologies I talked
about the hybrid memory systems as
single level stores I think there's a
lot of hope there and an orthogonal
problem regardless of whatever you use
your memory you develop device your
memory with you need to solve the
problem of quality of service if it's a
shared resource across different
workloads and I've already giving you
the three principles cooperation across
the stack better than worst case design
and heterogeneity I'll acknowledge a lot
of people whose effort actually went
into this talk I guess I'm the messenger
here but basically my students my
collaborators and at different places
and funding with the generous plan
without that generous funding we were we
wouldn't have been able to talk about
any of this or do any of this and one
thing our point is we have a lot of open
source tools so if you're interested I
mean we're going we're going to put out
even more the Wii emulator to actually
does enable design space exploration for
very different kinds of memory it's a
flexible DRAM simulator that models HP
my die oh and different kinds of things
and we have different memory simulators
at different granularities and an error
model that we developed in collaboration
with Facebook by examining their systems
actually all of their systems are
looking at the memory error occurrences
and the entire Facebook server fleet
okay thank you if you have to take more
questions
so for years you had this very nice
split between architecture and
microarchitecture the programmers use
the architecture and the micro
architecture to do whatever it wanted to
as long as it didn't violate that
contract mhm you seem to be violating
that contract okay what's the impact of
that gonna be okay let me let me think
about this I think I'm not violating
that contract I'm just thinking about
this finding a different contract well
you're making your microarchitecture
today you're gonna make architecture
exactly but that's really going to
restrict the flexibility of the hardware
design we've made good advantage of that
slim that's right I think that's the
that's where the interesting research
challenge lies how do you design an
interface where you can still do the
innovation without changing that
interface all the time and the software
is written and I think there are
interfaces that are amenable to that for
example if you're a package based
interface to memory and not advocating
it but I think if you have packet reason
to reach the memory the packets can
remain the same but then you can
communicate different things within
those packets right you can over time
adjusts those packets somehow I agree
it's a research challenge yeah and how
do you do it efficient before it becomes
an issue also but I'm not suggesting
that you should break everything just
design more clean interfaces such that
innovation can happen independently
stealth but we can't exploit we can
still scale yes what about another level
of memory management so that
intelligence such as the OS or system
management software could change the
mapping and do a copy so opted to
optimize based on the measured
characteristics so that makes sense
depending on what that layer looks like
so you're thinking basically some
software layer or hardware layer or
something
memory management to switch between
where things are stored we need to do
movements and then then switch work or
something actually another layer that
actually manages your memory it makes a
lot of sense and we ended up because
different phases of a computation have
different access paths yes so it's all
that's agreed I agree but I think with
with the if you have the computation key
for both T in memory you maybe there is
a different way of doing things like no
yeah yes we're very take advantage of
the certain technology that in memory
computation or search engine or
something so actually that's that's what
we did with the graph analytics research
that I didn't describe as much but
basically we've looked at page rank
computation and that's very memory bound
and if you're doing that graph analytics
over a huge graph you can get 14x
higher performance according to our
results and 10x reduction system energy
I think big graph analytics like
applications is one example but I don't
think it's limited to that graph
analytics only
you